Swiss army man is directed by two guys
named Daniel as well as starring Daniel
Radcliffe and Paul Dano lots of dance
dan overload how do I even begin
explaining this movie so Paul Danos
character is stranded on an island he's
about to hang himself and then he sees a
body wash up on shore that dead body is
Daniel Radcliffe this stops him from
doing this and as he approaches this
body he discovers that this thing can do
just about anything it can fart and
become a jet ski it can fight fires with
its fingers and it really wants to know
about life and it has a lot of things to
say so paul dano starts teaching the
dead body version of daniel radcliffe
about life and love and they both try to
make it out of the woods together I
think I did it I think I think I
described it I actually have seen this
movie two times the first time I saw it
I was like I need to see that again
before I say a word about that movie so
I saw it again today and I love this
movie
it is impossible really to compare this
movie to anything else and even if you
did you just be comparing multiple
movies and mashing them together trying
to make this movie which is saying
something this is an extremely original
and strange weird movie the direction in
this movie is beautiful and it's
wonderfully edited and the soundtrack I
don't want to spoil anything but the
soundtrack is so cool it's so different
just like all of this movie it's just so
different and weird I'd love it the
filmmakers here have taken something
very childish farting and used it as a
metaphor to describe things that we keep
in things we hide but it's not just
about holding in farts and not wanting
to fart in front of other people it's
about things we want to say to people
things we want to say to people we love
or maybe somebody that we'd like to talk
to or get to know better but we're too
afraid because we don't want to be
ridiculed
so we bottle all these things inside of
us the film explores that really well
and there's a great scene where the two
lead characters are laying around a
campfire and Paul Danos telling
Radcliffe all these things he can't do
say in front of people because ah no you
can't say that oh no no don't say that
don't do that and he's like why are we
even trying to go back home that place
sounds horrible you can't do anything
fun there and when he said that I was
like damn that's true paul dano in this
movie is fabulous he is so good so funny
and one of the things I really have to
say is this movie is funny it is so
hilarious there is so much great humor
in this movie and most of it is due to
Daniel Radcliffe and what I think is his
best performance and I'm a big Harry
Potter fan I like Harry Potter like the
Harry Potter movies I think he's great
as Harry Potter and I basically liked
him and most everything I've seen him in
but here he gives what I think is my
favorite performance he's ever given and
he is comic gold in this movie I always
see him in interviews and I'm like this
guy's funny he's likable who's going to
give him a role to really capitalize on
that and in this movie he gets to he is
astoundingly funny as this dead body
that has quite a bit of questions about
life and I have to say this I heard this
movie got booed a can and people walked
out and tons of people just left before
it even ended before they even got to
the halfway point and I know somebody
who went to the Cannes Festival who
confirmed this it wasn't just media
reports blowing it up that really pisses
me off this is an original and different
movie that should be supported in an
entertainment world dominated with
sequels and reboots and remakes and
sequels you need to support movies like
this guys why the hell were you walking
out of this movie just because it's a
little different my only issue with this
movie is that I don't think they quite
stick the ending there's some really
cool stuff that happens and it makes you
just go like oh that's cool I like that
but then you try to connect things and
you're like I don't know if that makes
sense
still Swiss army man is a drastically
original movie with two amazing
performances a great soundtrack great
humor excellent direction I'm gonna give
it an A
guys again if you're big fans and movies
like I am you got to support movies like
this that take artistic chances that
take risks that do their best to just be
like this is a movie we're going to make
we don't care this is what we're making
and I have to support that I got to give
major props to these guys and just to
let you know I am still running my
promotion with audible.com if you go to
audible.com slash Chris you can download
a ton of awesome
audiobooks hundreds of thousands you can
get a free 30-day trial at audible.com
slash Chris these guys have been so
great in the past I've gotten a lot of
great feedback from you you can download
tons of audiobooks to your iPad your mp3
player your computer anything you really
want to download it to it's probably
going to work and they have such a great
selection tons of awesome stuff so
please visit audible.com slash Chris and
check out that for a free 30-day trial
of that service you guys are the best
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen iced